foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear so you guys know I mean anyone who
has been around here for any length of
time at all uh knows that I love Dario
Argento uh just recently in fact I
picked uh 1977's Suspiria as one of my
all-time favorite horror films uh that
was over on scare Salon I did kind of
like a you know best horror films of
every year since I was born Suspiria
being one of my favorites from 1977 but
like I said not just one of my favorites
from 1977 it's one of my favorites of
all time I'm also a really big fan of
Dario argento's uh early gialo films uh
bird with the crystal plumage you know
deep red tenebrae Opera uh several of
which I've covered on you know various
posts and videos uh now in my opinion I
think I've brought this up before but
I think that probably in my opinion uh
1996's stendall syndrome was his last
really good film some of his post 1990s
work did have some flashes of Brilliance
here and there uh but I kind of feel
like after that the movies that he did
after that sort of ranged from just
mediocre to actively awful and uh in
that latter category obviously I'm
mostly looking at that CGI praying
mantis from Dracula 3D which was just a
[ __ ] show of uh epic proportions
but in spite of all this knowing all of
this as I do uh I was actually super
jazzed for you know at this point Dario
Argento being 82 years old but I was
really looking forward to him returning
to the director's chair for the 2022
film dark glasses which I've also seen
called black glasses and I think that
that's because the Italian title which
is uh okialeneri if I pronounce that
even remotely correctly I'm pretty sure
I didn't that's what that translates to
that actually translates to black
glasses but I think in the United States
at least it's called dark glasses so uh
so I was really really excited about it
and uh shutter just added it not too
long ago I didn't get to see it in the
theater I think it did get a limited
theatrical release but I don't know if
it uh played around here now going into
it like I knew that I was gonna be you
know have to manage my expectations
somewhat because I knew that any new
movie that he made wasn't going to
approach the same exalted realm as his
Classics obviously because nothing he's
made since the 90s has uh you know and
he's you know quite an elderly man now
so but I was still curious like to see
what he was gonna do but you know I
couldn't help but be cautiously
optimistic though like as I sat down in
front of shutter with my little cup of
coffee to like watch this movie so how
was it it was fine it was fine uh solid
six or seven if I wanted to break it
down to a numerical score which I don't
usually do because like I said it's a
little bit reductive
um it was like kind of subdued and it
was a little bit predictable maybe even
in spots like a little bit clunky I kind
of felt like uh the acting was kind of
hit or miss it was mostly good but you
know some of the stuff was not that
great I will say that the suspense was
almost non-existent because for various
reasons but one of the reasons being
that the killer was revealed far too
early and there were a couple of
sequences in there that made absolutely
no sense and were just sort of really
really dumb uh especially in regard to
some baffling decisions that some of the
characters made and the way that they
reacted or underreacted to certain
events I'm trying not to give too much
away because this movie's brand new but
you know so there was there was some
negatives there on the other hand though
uh it did have a handful of some
enjoyably nasty Gore sequences
particularly toward the beginning and
had some decent visual some nice camera
work nothing overtly like or more
operatic or over the top like his early
stuff but still like really really nice
cinematography uh had a good score by
the French musician uh Arno rebatini I
think Daft Punk was supposed to do the
score but they uh broke up so they
dropped out so they got somebody else to
do it and I have to say that um I I kind
of have been seeing like mixed reviews
of the acting in this like generally but
and like I said I agree with some of it
like in some of the peripheral
characters and whatnot but I will say
that the kind of the two lead
performances uh which are by uh elenia
pastorelli she's like at the main role
and Asia Argento who's kind of like a
significant supporting character uh were
actually largely good I thought they did
really well uh the characters here
matter of fact were actually like pretty
interesting I thought and quite
sympathetic and that went a long way
toward getting me like emotionally
invested in the story and like caring
about what happened to them because I
thought they were interesting compelling
characters keep in mind though that this
is more on the the yellow end of the
scale rather than like the straight
forward horror end matter of fact I'd
probably call this a thriller that just
happens to have a couple of like really
excessively gruesome murders in it
rather than a more traditional horror
movie per se so from what I could
determine this was actually adapted from
an old screenplay like I guess like
Dario Argento and Franco Fiorini and
Carlo lucarelli they wrote it like a
long time ago like 20 years ago back in
2002 and then just kind of like stuffed
it in the Attic somewhere and then uh I
think Ozzie Argento found it and like
brought it I was like hey maybe you
should you know we should like work on
this or collaborate on this and Ozzie
Argento actually uh serves as an
executive producer on it so uh dark
glasses actually starts out with a touch
of foreshadowing I guess as our main
protagonist who's kind of like a
high-end sex worker named Diana and she
slaps on the titular accessories the
dark glasses in order to look at a solar
eclipse now little does she realized
that this eclipse is actually kind of
like a symbol of her Impending Descent
Into Darkness saying as she could call
it in more ways than one meanwhile
there's a serial killer on the loose in
Rome and he's targeting upscale escorts
uh and one early victim actually meets a
very very grisly end she gets like
garotted in the street uh by a guy that
jumps out of some bushes and stuff and
it's it's pretty nasty you know what I
mean pretty nasty like you can see like
the trachea of like popping out and
stuff like that and I'm like yep that
starry you are right you know what I
mean and he's just like lingers on it
yeah it's pretty gross uh so after this
whole serial killer thing is established
we kind of like return to Diana's
character and we get a little bit of a
glimpse into her regular like work a day
life which you know consists of you know
she's an escort so you know you have
some very kindly generous clients and
then you have like a smattering of
violent douchebags so you know so not
too long into the proceedings Diana
become comes the next Target the next
focus of the Killer and one night he
starts chasing her like she gets in her
car and like takes off and he starts
chasing her with his you know standard
issue White Band which I think actually
started out as a black band but then
like he paints it at some point like to
keep from getting caught so during this
car chase Diana actually ends up
smashing into another vehicle which
contains a Chinese family so like the
father who's driving the car is killed
the mom is injured so bad that she's in
a coma and the young son in the back
seat uh whose name is chin he's actually
played by uh Andrea Chang is completely
unharmed so Diana is actually blinded in
the accident and the doctors aren't real
confident that she's ever gonna get her
sight back so obviously she's very
dispirited by this and uh Diana goes end
up going back home but she gets cheered
up somewhat by uh the burgeoning
friendship with her very compassionate
caseworker whose uh name is Rita who's
played by Asia Argento who's actually
like great in this role I almost didn't
recognize her because you know usually
if if Dari or Argento is going to put
Asia in a movie
um you know it's going to be like more
of like a sexy vampy kind of role and
there's usually nudity
um but she's actually not naked in this
one and she's actually just like more of
a regular woman I don't want to say like
Dowdy or like plain necessarily but they
definitely like do de-glam her a little
bit and I think she does like a really
really great job but she's like a really
good character so she basically comes on
board and she's helping Diana to adjust
to her disability you know what I mean
like showing her to use the white cane
and and how to use like all of the
resources that are available to her you
know uh one of these adjustments
includes the procuring of a seeing eye
dog a very good girl named nerea who
actually factors into the plot later on
I was actually as soon as the dog was
introduced I immediately got really um
anxious because I was just kind of like
nothing bad better happen to that dog I
don't know the spoiler alert spoiler
alert spoiler alert not too much of a
spoiler alert but I just want to tell
people it's like the dog's okay you know
what I mean the dog doesn't get killed
all right so I'll just put that in there
because I know people are like sense and
I'm sensitive about that kind of stuff
too and like I like to know ahead of
time just so I can like prepare myself
but like the dog's okay the dog doesn't
get hurt so not only is Diana kind of
like frustrated at her new limitations I
guess uh she also feels horribly
horribly guilty about her part in the
accident that ended up taking away
Chin's parents you know the kid that was
in the back seat of the car so she
actually goes to visit him at the
orphanage and he's initially like pretty
hostile like because he blames her for
the accident but he eventually kind of
comes around and really he does kind of
like a whole 180 because he decides that
he likes Diana so much that he runs away
from the orphanage and goes and like
hides out in her house like he wants to
stay with her uh which actually ends up
causing some trouble with the child
protective services with the authorities
like down the line as you might imagine
although it doesn't cause quite as much
trouble as you might think which is
which is a little weird but okay so as
Diana is kind of become becoming
acclimatized to her new reality uh the
Killer is actually still stalking her
because you know she got away and could
potentially uh identify him although it
seems more like a personal Vendetta to
be honest it's not never really made
clear
um and because of her blindness she's
actually more vulnerable than she was
before obviously
um of course she still has her support
system she has you know Rita who's very
reliable and uh chin who helps her out
he kind of like essentially like moves
into her apartment and like helps her
out with her day-to-day stuff like
grocery shopping and everything but
um you know the fact that the murderer
is still pursuing her for whatever
reason
um puts their lives in danger as well
and it all kind of like builds up to not
gonna lie kind of like a tepid climax
like in the third act as Diana kind of
becomes forced to confront the killer
like they're all trying to like figure
out like how they can take him out or
whatever so as I mentioned this one
isn't great but it's not really all that
bad either
um it's certainly a lot better than his
last Abomination which as I mentioned
was Dracula 3D from 2012. and in a lot
of ways it's kind of a throwback to the
giallo films of the 70s or maybe I guess
like a Pastiche of Dario argento's own
previous Works in that sub-genre uh it
does have a few moments of batshittery
especially
um the one bewildering scene which
everybody's talking about with the water
snakes uh which I won't spoil and the
characters themselves like sometimes
make some perplexing choices like for
example I think like even the main
character she does some weird [ __ ] too
but the thing that I mostly wanted to
point out was the two cops who are kind
of investigating I guess they're maybe
investigating the serial killer too but
they're kind of like investigating
Chin's whereabouts because like I said
he ran away from the orphanage and
they're not really sure where he went
they kind of pull some questionable [ __ ]
toward Diana and then seemingly forget
get any police training that they may
have received like when the killer like
kind of comes toward them like in his
van or whatever but you know I don't
want to get like lean too hard into that
because maybe for all I know like
Italian police really are this
antagonistic and kind of witless so
for all I know this portrayal could be
entirely accurate I don't know if
there's any Italians out there like let
me know um maybe this completely tracks
I don't know the best parts of the movie
I gotta say were the First Act um you
know with kind of had all the murders
and gorks there's not really a lot of
murders or Gore I mean there's Gore but
it's pretty like few and far between
there's not like a lot of murders but I
liked the first act and I surprisingly I
liked the second act which was mostly
just Diana and Rita like and chin and
Diana like adjusting to her blindness
and also like you know the burner
mystery stuff like the killer was kind
of like lurking around in the background
too and like kind of her trying to like
figure out where he was at and like if
he was coming after her and [ __ ] like
but the murder mystery thing was kind of
in the background so it was just kind of
like her adjusting to the blindness and
I actually kind of like that because it
gave something of a depth to the
characters that I mean usually in
argento's films you know he's more of a
visuals guy he's more of like a that I
don't want to say a plot guy because
he's not but he doesn't usually like
give his characters a lot of depth
because he's just concerned turned with
like the visuals and the set pieces and
stuff like that so this actually had was
a lot more character focused than his
stuff usually is
um I have to say that the third act
though which which is mainly like uh
comprised of like just an extended Chase
or a skin extended escape from the
killer you know trying to outwit him or
whatever it felt kind of oddly inert and
a little bit underwhelming
um and the final scene was just like
really flat and strange I didn't really
like get it I thought it was like
building up to something and I was just
like oh that's it all right if you want
to end your movie like that it was just
I don't know it was just very very odd
uh and also I have to say unlike a
standard Jello film because this is
technically a Jello film I guess even
though there's some aspects of it that
aren't
um but unlike your standard gyllo film
there weren't really a bunch of like
potential suspects or like red herrings
to focus on I guess there were some but
not really that many it wasn't really
pushed all that hard and in any case
like the killer was actually pretty
obvious quite early on in the film and I
kind of feel like maybe Dario Argento
realized this and actually revealed the
killer fully about halfway through the
not very long film I think the movie's
only 86 minutes might not even have been
halfway now that I'm thinking about it
I'm not sure exactly at what point but I
was just like oh okay we're showing the
killer now and we're not even pretending
that it's a secret okay fair enough but
yeah so there was that but the fact that
he did that though I feel like it kind
of like drained the movie of any
suspense
because there wasn't really any mystery
to it it was just more like oh that's
who the killer was which we kind of
suspected all along anyway and you know
as soon as he was introduced and then
it's like the rest of it is just kind of
like getting away from him kind of thing
you know what I mean it wasn't there
wasn't any mystery is like oh my God it
was really that guy there was no twists
or nothing like that so like I said
that's what I meant about it being kind
of predictable was that it was there
weren't really any twisted or surprises
in the story uh I have to say too that
the Killer's motivation for his crimes
were kind of like underwritten and like
a little bit lame you know what I mean
it just seemed again like a
yeah it was just kind of like meh you
know what I mean I sound like I'm
[ __ ] on this and I'm really not um I
did actually enjoy this movie I did find
it interesting enough to I wasn't boring
or anything like that so in spite of all
these negatives and caveats and stuff
like this I actually would recommend
this to Argento fans who were curious to
see it but I'm also recommending that
you go into it without expecting much
you might be pleasantly surprised if you
if you go in expecting it to suck it
actually doesn't suck it's actually like
pretty good but if you go into it like
expecting that it's gonna suck or
expecting it's gonna be like Dracula 3D
then I think you'll be pleasantly
surprised because it's like much much
better than that I don't think dark
glasses will turn any new fans on to his
work necessarily and to be frank like I
think that if this hadn't been made by
Dario Argento I think it'd probably just
be like a middling movie and like
everyone just kind of like forget about
it in a couple of months but on the
other hand as a director he's certainly
done way way worse movies than this um
it's absolutely it was absolutely decent
enough to kind of make me excited did
make me hope that he'll live long enough
to make another movie because I think
there were some interesting ideas in
here particularly if he wants to go the
giallo route that I think could be like
amped up or kind of like you know what I
mean I still want to see what he can do
even though he's older now and this
actually kind of like even though it
wasn't fantastic it actually made me
like oh well if he makes another movie
like we'll see you know what I mean so
it like really did it was a little bit
of a pleasant surprise I don't know if I
was necessarily expecting it to suck but
I went into it thinking that it wasn't
going to be very good and it was
actually like better than I was
expecting it to be so let's uh let's
call it that so if you've seen it let me
know what you thought about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
flicker zafira I'll see you guys again
on the next one bye